[Music]
it's only 9
30. an oldham town center is already
dead
if i wasn't getting paid and i weren't
working i won't come out and socialize
in the pub
it's just not the same anymore there's
not really enough people out for any
trouble
but there is a curfew to enforce so it's
new for us it's new for them
so it's about us going out and speaking
to everybody and making sure everyone
understands
we usually finish at 5 a.m on a on a
weekend
really so because everything's closed
clothes are closed
everything's closed it's you know we
need to get used to it
last log down everyone was out really
yeah
not following the rules in it they need
to be taught
and that's it 10 o'clock everything now
has to be closed the one exception is
takeaways but
only if they're doing deliveries not
this
walking in for chicken wings at 10 40
on union street a man just left here
with a takeaway
it is now 22 11 at night
and you have broken the law this is
where the pandemic has brought us
the police and the council having to
stretch already thin
resources to try and enforce all this
he's been given a warning notice
if he breaches and
does that again and we were aware of
that
then he'll get a fixed penalty for which
the first penalty is a thousand pounds
this curfew is designed to reduce
people's potential exposure to the virus
everyone's like right this strict rule
you need to be home but
any day do you realize no one's gonna
follow that
especially the younger people they're
not gonna block right we need to be in
by 10 o'clock
blah blah blah they've already had five
weeks of tighter coved restrictions in
oldham but it's still spreading
and like so many other towns the most
deprived communities
like saint mary's are being hit hardest
nobody's respecting the rules
yeah nobody know i don't know they feel
like you know nobody can tell them what
to do and
people still party together people still
chill together indoor
you can target people flouting the rules
when they're out and about
but it is here in people's homes where
the second wave is spreading
just as fast tom parmenter sky news
oldham